a massive expansion set to come to Area
15 we're getting a glimpse of what it'll
look like Victoria Saha joins us live
near Rancho and Desert Inn with more hi
Victoria
hi guys well Area 15 is tucked away from
the strip right now I'm standing in the
lot next to it that they bought and
they're expecting to stretch Area 15
into 20 more Acres it's going to be a
big transformation for this part of town
[Music]
known as Area 15 District where you can
find yourself getting lost in the
immersive art and dining experience now
there will be 20 more Acres of that with
Universal Parks and Resorts bringing in
horror entertainment and surrounding it
we'll have 450
000 square feet of shops office space
and residential areas this expansion
means good news for those who work and
live in the area says councilwoman
Olivia Diaz who represents Ward 3. this
is completely Economic Development
bringing someone of the size of
Universal Studios is snow small feet and
we know that year after year their
horror events in October sell out in
Orlando and la and we're looking forward
to Las Vegas getting that much attention
since Area 15 first opened in 2020 it
brought in over 1 000 full-time jobs
their CEO Winston Fisher says with this
expansion the job opportunities will
double that number
so they tell me that they're expecting
to break ground this year and hopefully
by 2025 the final product will be open
reporting live from area 15 Victoria
Saha 8 News Now